filmgoers have finally discovered
something Deadpool's longtime comics
fans have known for a while the Merc
with a mouth is nearly impossible to
kill he soaks up the bullets survives
buildings burning down and even regrows
a hand in the weirdest way possible very
crazy are usually really small not the
size of the KFC spork it's easy to leave
the theater wondering exactly how anyone
could ever defeat someone was such an
amazing healing factor fortunately years
of Deadpool comics have offered an array
of technique for accomplishing just such
a goal supervillains avert your eyes
here are just a few ways to defeat
Deadpool it takes a planet like most
Marvel characters Deadpool have died in
the comics and in a pretty staggering
variety of ways
he recently bet the big chimichanga and
Deadpool 45 when an entire planet fell
on him which isn't too out of line for a
normal Deadpool adventure anyhow
Deadpool was just one of many casualties
during Marvel's latest Secret Wars event
in which different parallel worlds
collide with each other with the
intention of thinning out the
complicated multiverse and making Marvel
comics a bit more reader friendly by the
end of the story there are just two
parallel earth the one we know and love
and Marvel's ultimate earth which smack
into one another like most comic book
deaths this was a temporary arrangement
at mr. fantastic and his family
eventually helped recreate the entire
multiverse Deadpool included the event
certainly cements that there are some
things even Deadpool's healing factor
can take on like reality falling apart
take away his powers Deadpool's main
thing is his impressive mutant healing
factor which allows him to bounce back
from nearly anything without the ability
to regrow body parts he's just a guy
with a lot of weapons a very sick human
body and no sense of self-preservation
so how can you steal Deadpool's mojo I'm
gonna get you I'm gonna get you
when it comes to the powering
superpeople there are a surprising
number of options Scarlet Witch no to be
stripped most mutants of their powers
during Marvel's House of M events per
ton the nuclear option there's always
the mutant leech as his unfortunate name
implies leech has the ability to
effectively turn off the powers of
nearby super humans and the mutants if
Deadpool were in the same general area
as leech he could be killed just like a
regular person providing you could get
past the dozens of machine guns and
swords he usually carries yeah good luck
with that
he also barely escapes death when
confronting the walrus a villain with a
magic power cancelling hammer so where
physical violence will usually fail a
little bit of magic goes a long way
science if you don't want to allow
superpowers there's also science the
answer could be as simple as a special
serum using Deadpool 54 which made him
handsome but also took away his healing
factor don't have access to a chemistry
set carbonadium is also an option like
vibranium and adamantium carbonadium is
another fictional Marvel method of
villains like Doctor Octopus and Omega
red of use over the years it's one of
the reasons I make a red is such a
deadly foe for Wolverine his radioactive
tentacles are able to negate Logan's
healing factor while Deadpool hasn't
felt a deadly sting of carbonadium
himself a Deadpool from a parallel
universe used some carbonadium katanas
have he killed every living hero the
swords were able to successfully
decapitate Wolverine and turn off his
healing factor so no one is safe cure
his cancer the sad truth is that without
his hyperactive healing powers Deadpool
would have already died from especially
aggressive cancer fortunately his
healing factor is in harmony with the
disease helping him to grow new cells of
the exact rate that he loses them even
though it doesn't really fix his freaky
face as a result Deadpool's level of
healing seems to be a bit above the
usual Wolverine level this was
demonstrated in a rather grisly way when
a group of Scrolls decided to steal
Deadpool's powers for themselves but
didn't steal his illness that meant that
their bodies were healing way too much
way too fast causing the scroll of
warriors to become swollen and deformed
until they exploded theoretically the
same thing would happen to Deadpool of
any enterprising villain were able to
his cancer it's just too much of a good
thing give him the feels despite often
being written of an insane and violent
parody one consistent quality Deadpool
has is that he formed strong bonds of
friends teammates and kids who else
could have formed a rapport with
negasonic teenage warhead you
chicken-noodle nothing compared to you
Sinead O'Connor 1997 very useful
that's bonding with young people is
rooted in the comics as well with
Deadpool forming a protective
relationship with Evan a young clone of
apocalypse what does this have to do
with defeating Deadpool well in true
comics tradition he's just like every
other hero he's easily manipulated when
it comes to people he cares about
Deadpool was willing to risk his own
life in order to redeem Evan and stop
him from going down the dark path of
apocalypse all it takes is a little
emotional leverage to defeat dead for a
broken heart might not kill him
but it would totally keep him out of
action for a while heroes and villains
even before our planet was dropped on
him both the good guys and bad guys have
actually been defeating Deadpool for
years Santos is one of the biggest
villains in the Marvel Universe even
when he isn't wielding the Infinity
Gauntlet he's able to obliterate
characters that are otherwise really
difficult to kill wasting no time
Thanos kills Deadpool on the second page
of the four issue Deadpool vs. Panos
miniseries Deadpool is legitimately dead
until he's brought back to life by Death
herself to of course have a crush on
Deadpool and that's not even the last
all-powerful opponent that tangled with
Wade Loki was actually able to defeat
Deadpool in the most bizarre way
possible forget about magic and powerful
of guardian weapons which would probably
do a good job cutting Deadpool down to
size
Loki's curse results in Deadpool being
annoyed by almost everything in his life
and the creation of possibly the best
Deadpool costume of all time and as a
pristine Asst the curse also prevents
Deadpool from killing himself whenever
he tries it's crazy even for Deadpool
the potential to defeat Deadpool seems
to lie in the hands of any number of
Marvel characters the century with his
Superman level strength and his
willingness to kill have a reputation
for throwing people into the Sun which
Deadpool probably wouldn't be able to
recover from mr. fantastic is known for
trapping people in inescapable pocket
universe
molecule man can control matter at an
atomic level and a Deadpool without
atoms there's no Deadpool at all
and we're not saying that Squirrel Girl
can defeat just about anyone but
Squirrel Girl thanks for watching click
the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel let's check out all this
cool stuff we know your love to
[Music]